Dans 366 vidéos il fallait que ça arrive... je suis tombé malade !
Mercredi dernier j'ai joué mon spectacle à Belouze dans un château, et il faisait froid et je pense que je suis tombé malade là-bas.
Alors hier, comme j'avais une vidéo d'avance, celle avec la Carologie je l'ai mise en ligne, mais aujourd'hui i: faut que je tourne.
Parce que je le prendrai vraiment mal si je ratai le défi d'une vidéo par jour pendant un an juste parce que je suis malade.
Mais j'étais bien passé au travers cette année.
Bref ! Salut ! Aujourd'hui dans ce hors sujet je vous propose que l'n s'attarde sur l'origine d'un nom et pas n'importe quel nom, puisqu'il s'agit de celui de Sherlock Holmes.
Prenez votre loupe, allumez votre pipe et c'est parti !
[générique]
Sherlock Holmes est donc capable d'incroyables déductions en regardant une personne, un objet, en prenant en compte le contexte, et en établissant ses hypothèses.
L' approche qu'a ce personnage de fiction est toujours rationnel depuis sa création en roman jusqu'à toutes les interprétations récentes qui a pu avoir en film ou en série.
Ce personnage fictif, donc a été conçu, pensé et né dans l'esprit de Sir Arthur Conan Doyle.
Il a d'ailleurs confessé dans une interview d'avoir eu l'idée en 1886, alors qu'il avait encore son cabinet de médecine à Plymouth.
Il y a vraiment 3 choses qui sont intéressantes, d'abord à propos de Sherlock Holmes, c'est l'origine de Sherlock Holmes, de son nom et de son prénom, l'origine aussi du personnage en lui même tel qu'il a été décrit, et le rapport qu'avait au rationnel Sir Arthur Conan Doyle.
Ou plutôt même à l'irrationnel.
Pour le prénom de Sherlock, Conan Doyle avait expliqué qu'il a gardé toute sa vie le carnet où il avait fait son brain storming pour trouver le prénom.
Il ne voulait pas que le prénom représente une caractéristique du personnage en lui même, donc il ne voulait pas d'un M. Futé, ou d'un M. Rusé qui aurait donné Mister Sharps par exemple, en anglais.
Alors il se positionne sur le prénom Sherington d'abord.
Puis Sherinton, il enlève le G.
Mais il trouve que la prononciation n'est pas très fluide.
Puis, il s'est rappelé qu'au cours de sa vie il avait croisé un joueur de criquet qui s'apellait Sherlock.
Ca y ressemblait un peu mais c'était plus facile à prononcer.
Et ce prénom était aussi l'auteur d'un des livres de médecine qu'il avait chez lui, et celui d'un célèbre violoniste qu'il appréciait particulièrement, donc c'était acté, ce sera Sherlock.
Et pour le nom de famille Holmes, il avait prévu au départ que ce soit Hope, qui signifie "espoir" en anglais.
Et c'était surtout le nom d'un baleinier sur lequel il avait servi en 1980, enfin, du moins à partir de 1980 parce que je crois qu'il est resté un an dessus.
Attention ! Il faudrait vérifier cette information, je ne suis pas sûr.
Il servait à bord en tant que chirurgien sur le bateau pendant une chasse à la baleine.
Néanmoins il se refuse encore à donner comme nom de famille quelque chose qui a une caractéristique précise de qui sera le personnage.
Et comme ça veut dire "espoir" il y a un peu de confusion.
Alors il porte son choix sur quelqu'un qui existe, qui est un auteur de roman, de poésie et principalement à la base de livre de médecine, c'est quelqu'un dont il est fan, c'est Oliver Wendell Holmes.
C'est comme ça qu'il a trouvé le nom et le prénom de Sherlock Holmes.
Mais ce qui est encore plus intéressant c'est que le personnage en lui même, qui il est, est plus qu'inspiré d'une autre personnage qui s'appelle Joseph Beal.
Professeur d'anatomie d'Edinbourg qui enseignait à Conan Doyle quand il était à l'université.
Il adoré observer les gens, leurs vêtements, leurs mains, leurs caractéristiques, peut être leur accent quand ils parlaient, pour essayer de déduire un maximum de choses par la logique.
Durant les cours qu'il donnait, il encourageait ses élèves à faire comme lui avec leur propre passion.
Et il prenait beaucoup de plaisir à bluffer les gens et à faire des révélations sur les personnes avant même qu'il n'est commencé à engager la conversation.
Le plus amusant avec Conan Doyle qui est l'auteur qui a créé le personnage de fiction qui est surement le plus rationnel et le plus amoureux de l’esprit logique.
Et de la déduction en général, et c'est aussi quelqu'un qui avait la plus grande croyance auprès des médiums et dans la spiritualité en général.
Conan Doyle était convaincu qu'il y avait une vie après la mort et il a écrit de nombreux livres à ce sujet et sur le paranormal.
Il était d'ailleurs au fil des années devenu très ami avec Harry Houdini, le célèbre magicien Houdini, qui à l'époque cherchait à rentrer en contacte avec sa femme qui était décédée.
On pourrait en reparler de ça si vous voulez, mettez le moi dans les commentaires.
Je pourrai faire un sujet là dessus parce que c'est assez passionnant.
Mais Houdini qui était déçu de n'avoir que rencontré en fait que des charlatans, s'était mis dans une quête de les discréditer tous.
Malgré ça, et c'est là où c'est drôle la force de la conviction, Conan Doyle...
[caméra tombe]
Je recadre car la caméra est tombée.
Je disais donc, malgré ça, et c'est là qu'on peut voir la force des convictions, Conan Doyle était persuadé qu'Harry Hodini avait de réels pouvoirs.
Des pouvoirs de médium, des pouvoirs magiques.
Il l'a d'ailleurs écrit noir sur blanc dans un de ses livres qui 'appelle "Le bord de l'inconnu".
Et Houdini n'a jamais réussi à le convaincre que ce qu'il faisait lui, n'étaient que de simples tours de magie, avec des trucages de magicien.
J'espère que ce condensé des origines de ce personnage de Sherlock Holmes vous aura plu. C'est mon personnage de fiction préféré et de loin.
Si c'est le cas, n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en l'air.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir, puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an du premier janvier au 31 décembre, donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Oui, ce coup si j'ai bon, parce que ça faisait deux jours que je me trompais dans les heures. [rires]
Demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[musique]